can you tell the story of Shelley
miscavige and the Mystery surrounding
her I saw that there is quite a bit of
mystery yeah
so Shelley miscavich for many years held
the job of her post in the sea
organization was David miscavige's
assistant that was her post it's
important to truly understand
that and what that means because
um the fact that she was miscavige's
wife
is meaningless
and this is something that's hard to for
regular people in the regular world to
truly grasp how meaningless it is in
Scientology for sea org members who are
spouses it means nothing Your Role
matters more in within seaworg your
role's the only thing that matters so
let's say let's say if Shelley was
married to Dave but she worked in a
different organization
she would never be seen with him
ever publicly ever wouldn't travel with
him wouldn't go to events with him
nothing
sometime around 2006 2007 and I'm very
oversimplifying this okay Shelley
basically pissed off Dave to the point
where he's like okay I'm done with you
I'm going to take you off of your post
okay
at that point she was reassigned to
another confidential Scientology base up
in Twin Peaks California
um why am I the reason I'm providing
this type of detail is because we hear
that Shelley's missing yeah okay well
you realize the same people who report
that Shelley's missing are also the same
people who will tell you exactly where
she is
okay she works at this secretive CST
Church of spiritual technology base out
in Twin Peaks California I have personal
confirmation that she was seen and
spoken with by someone who knew her well
in I'll say 2019.
Shelley miscavige is missing in the
sense that
she hasn't been seen with David
miscavige since about 2006. but because
she's no longer his assistant
you would never see her with him as
opposed to like the mystery of of a
person that might be murdered this is
more of a reallocation within the
organization certain people who cover
Scientology
who have published stories
where Shelley's miscavige's family
member told
a story to another family member who
told the story to a friend who told the
story to a former Scientologist who told
the story to a journalist who published
the story
has created the impression that some of
Shelley miscavige's family members are
actually talking to the Press when in
fact that has never occurred
and so the very people who are
publishing about Shelley miscavige
missing have contributed to the fact
that Shelley miscavige does no longer
speak to those family members
because she thinks they're talking to
the Press when they never have
it's pretty messed up it's sad that she
because those those family members what
would be a way for her to
to recover to to flourish as a human
being to escape yeah
so
I believe the information that I have
that I verified I'm I'm putting out I'm
the one representing it's true without
revealing my sources sure that Shelley
was still actively in touch regularly
with family members outside of the sea
organization since about until about
2014.
so I mean regularly okay so there's no
question about her safety or uh during
that period and then someone else who
knew Shelly very well uh did see her and
actually have a conversation with her in
a public place in uh 2019 or 2020. now
somebody could still come along and be
like how do we know she's okay it's been
three years yeah okay you could say that
about anybody you know there there's a
the nature of working in the highest
levels of Scientology management at
these super secretive bases uh it's a
very weird and unique situation yeah it
has isolation baked in